cool I'm gonna try to speak loudly since
we don't have a mic but please stop me
if I am too quiet I'm Megan Hines
I'm a senior data scientist at BuzzFeed
but I primarily work on our tasty
property and today I'm going to talk
about recipe to Veck or how does my
robot know what recipes are related and
just to give you a little context in
case you don't know what tasty is tasty
is are kind of like mesmerizing
disembodied hand videos of people making
different recipes and within tasty we
have a bunch of different sub brands
like tasty vegetarian obviously if
you're vegetarians tasty junior for kids
proper tasty which is our UK offering
not just British cuisine just FYI cuz I
don't think there's that huge market for
that also tasty Japan this video is
actually one of our tasty Japan
producers I met with the producers of
this video three days ago in Tokyo so I
am very jet-lagged if I fall asleep
during this presentation please throw
something at me our content kind of
falls into two different clusters kind
of like really easy simple to make
comfort food stuff like three ingredient
no baked desserts or like one pan
chicken or like one pot pasta dishes
things like that and to steal some like
Great British Bake Off terminology
showstoppers so this is definitely like
falls into our showstopper category this
is a jiggly fluffy Japanese cheesecake
very difficult to make I've tried three
times and every time I come up with like
a kind of sad flat sweet omelette so
unless you're unless you're a pro baker
I would like start somewhere else so for
the last couple years we've had like a
really distributed social media strategy
BuzzFeed obviously is really into
virility and being on Facebook and in
2013 Facebook out rolled out
auto-playing videos and we spent a lot
of time observing what was doing well
and kind of realized that probably their
algorithm was optimizing for about forty
second videos so we kind of look
a bunch of different frames and then
eventually ended up focusing on making
40 second recipe videos in that time and
we launched our Facebook page in 2015
this turned out to be a really good
strategy for us because by 2016 we were
the fourth most-watched publisher on
Facebook like 1.8 billion views today
we've got 90 million fans on our
Facebook page and something like half of
all Millennials see a tasty video every
month and then in addition to Facebook
of course we're on YouTube and snapchat
and Instagram and what we realized was
two things that we have this really nice
like strategy for kind of shallow like
consumption and like far reach in that
like we've got a lot of fans and a lot
of people kind of know us a little bit
but for like our true like core power
fans people who were actually like going
home and cooking these recipes we really
weren't like offering them that much so
you think about trying to cook something
from a video you saw on Facebook just
even like going back and finding it
after you've have the ingredients that's
pretty difficult you're kind of just
like scrolling through feeds or like on
YouTube it's a little bit better but the
search still isn't really optimized for
finding recipes so it can be like kind
of a friction full negative experience
for people we think that most people are
kind of just watching these videos as
like a relaxing like bored at work
Network type of thing but we saw from
the comments that a lot of people were
actually cooking them because they would
send us like modifications or tips for
the recipes or they would post pictures
of the final final results so one of the
things you realize is when people are
actually cooking this it was a really
terrible experience finding the recipe
and then when you actually found it we
could see in our own video video
analytics that people were kind of
scrubbing in in the middle of videos and
re watching them or just like putting
them on repeat and watching them over
and over and over again in one session
the second thing you realize is these
aren't tasty users these are our
Facebook users YouTube users snapchat
username scream users at the end of the
day they are not our own users so we
know now that the like 42nd the
algorithm is no longer like optimizing
for this type of video
and that we're kind of like income and
unsustainable place and that Facebook
can kind of change the rock own to do
whatever they want if you guys have been
paying attention about two months ago
they started testing in Eastern Europe
this thing called the Explorer feed that
took all publisher content put it in
completely separate feed and then
publishers from Eastern Europe said that
they experienced about half the traffic
that they normally had so we decided
okay we want to do something for our
power users and we want to kind of put
ourselves in a little bit safer position
so for the last eight months my team has
been working on building an iOS app and
building an amp native and the amp
enabled website kind of smaller projects
we also built an Alexa skill on IOT
cooktop that connects with our app and
an app for Samsung smart fridge so we've
been really busy in the last couple
months and we've thought a lot about
like what we want these products to be
for our users and we've been thinking a
lot about like a digital cookbook or
something that makes it like really easy
for people to go back in and actually
use these for cooking rather than just
kind of like zoning out to them so when
we think about a cookbook and like what
kinds of recipes are gonna be around
like something like a chicken alfredo
pasta recipe probably gonna find other
kind of creamy like pasta recipes within
that so we thought what we wanted to do
was build a related recipes feed and we
could see from our own search data
within the tasty vertical that people in
the same session would maybe like search
pasta a couple times or search beef
stir-fry a couple of times so when
people are actually sitting down to cook
something they kind of have already have
an idea of what they want to make so by
being able to like find all these
related recipes we can potentially make
this like kind of exhausting search a
lot easier for our users and then the
second thing that does for us is we know
that the most highly trafficked recipe
pages are going to be the ones that we
have published most recently but say are
like recipes from the three years ago or
probably still you know just as good for
when you want to make dinner so this
kind of gives us an opportunity to
resurface older content and create some
recirculation
so you might wonder like why do we even
need to have a computer do this
don't we have humans making these
recipes that really understand our
content better than our like our
computer is ever going to understand and
I think we've heard this like anyone
who's worked with metadata knows that
human created metadata can be pretty
difficult I think we've heard this like
concept I had a couple evarin talks
today so early on we were working on a
project to categorize all of our
different recipes and we found out
pretty quickly that humans are not very
good at that
and there was some pretty like
devastating stuff that went on and that
first of all at BuzzFeed I think we have
had some issues metadata in that
previously when articles were written
the authors would say which part of the
website it would go on and they are
obviously very incentivized to get as
many views as possible
so one of the categories was just
BuzzFeed they went to the main page so
obviously everyone put everything under
BuzzFeed and we had no metadata for
those articles so kind of after that
experience they were kind of trained to
add as many tags as possible so that
they could maybe maximize the number of
views that their content could get so
we'd get things like teriyaki chicken
meatballs would be tagged as breakfast
and be like okay guys I don't know why
you're eating that for breakfast but
that's not gonna work for us
one of the like worst possible examples
that I saw was we had a collection of
mocktails which technically do not have
alcohol on them so a child could consume
them but I don't imagine there are very
many parents that would want us to be
like training their child to like crave
a Moscow Mule
so these tags actually power a module in
our app where we show kind of like
collections of recipes so a few days
after we launched the app this showed up
and I like my head just like kind of
exploded
so we know that we're not gonna like use
the producers tags they're not going to
decide which recipes are related
probably because they're just going to
find all of theirs and say there's a
related so we have to figure out some
other way to take this recipe data and
make it machine readable so I machine
learning there are a couple of different
methods for doing this and two really
common ones are dummy encoding and wave
one
so for dummy coding what you what you do
is you take your list of tokens and each
token becomes its own separate column of
binary zeros and ones for whether or not
it's there in that row and for label
encoding you take your whole list and
then you create a transformation of
integers so Paris so Tokyo becomes 2 in
this instance Paris becomes 1 so on and
so forth so both of these methods have
the same kind of problem in that they
don't really have an understanding of
how similar an ingredient might be so an
original recipe database that you
created I had about 12 different
versions of Greek yogurt you know like
full fat Greek yogurt or 2% Greek yogurt
or just regular yogurt so both of these
would have like no understanding that
these are really really similar things
they would be entirely different
integers or entirely different columns
and the process of going through and
like merging these things it's kind of
complicated because at some point it
does really matter if it's like a
fat-free thing or like a full fat thing
so like how deep do you want to go into
these things the other issue is liberal
encoder implies some type of ordinality
to your data and really at the end of
day there's no reason why a line would
be too and a lemon would be 4,000 so for
kind of both of these reasons I didn't
really want to move forward with these
methods I did look into some more
advanced methods like polynomial and
backward difference in helmert but none
of them really like solved in these
problems for me so what I've initially
landed on was deciding to create word
embeddings so when you have weird images
you can take raw text corpus and create
vector Revan tations of the words in
your and
corpus so for this example it would be
eggplant in this array of decimals so
word embeddings theoretically when you
plot them in an individual space should
have similar words end up spatially
closer together and then dissimilar
words farther apart so in this kind of
toy example porpoise and dolphin and
SeaWorld are kind of close together but
camera and Paris are kind of farther off
to the side there are a lot of different
ways to make word embeddings but they
all kind of come around this same type
concept of a word is characterized by
the company that it keeps you can create
them using TF idea factorization words
word co-occurrence matrix and most
famous of which being glove which was
created at Stanford there are a bunch of
different neural network implementations
but kind of the most famous one is word
Tyvek which is created at Google and
originally published by Thomas meek
cloth just like a two layer neural
network when I was started researching
this problem I did find that both glove
and word Tyvek produce very high quality
word embeddings but that glove works
better with really really large data
sets we kind of had like a medium or
like artisinal sized number of recipes
so I felt pretty confident moving
forward with word Tyvek which is what we
did so I just want to like give you a
little overview of how word Tyvek works
with the Skip Graham implementation so
first you're going to take a sentence
like the quick brown fox jumped over the
lazy dog and you're decomposing this
into context words and target words so
then Brown become the context words for
quick quick and fox are brown and brown
jumped for fox then each of these words
is initialized as a random vector of
very small values you're actually going
to have a separate vector for the word
as a context word and the word as a
target word and then you try to predict
the context words from the target words
using a soft max regression classifier
and continuous bag of words which is a
different implementation of word Tyvek
it's just the opposite of that you're
trying to predict the target words from
the context words so after you make your
prediction it's ridiculous and terrible
because it started completely randomly
so you're going to go back and make
updates to your word vectors using your
objective function and stochastic
gradient descent and then you just kind
of keep doing this over and over and
over again until you meet some stopping
criteria be that maximum number of
iterations or minimum change within your
vectors this is just kind of what it
looks like as neural network you have
your input vector your hidden layer and
then your output set and soft makes
classifier so you might be wondering
like how is this different from any
other neural network sounds like pretty
standard some of the things that were
detected differently from the neural
network implementations that came before
that was this concept of word pairs and
phrases so things that are like very
commonly together get treated as phrases
rather than single words the big example
for this is Boston Globe so Boston and
Globe separately means something very
different than the newspaper so the
frequency that these pairings come up
together means that they can be treated
separately as phrases rather than single
words we also do subsampling in word
Tyvek so really frequent words become
less frequent in your training examples
so this is kind of just like a slicker
away than using something like stop
words list and removing those things
manually like we can kind of figure out
what our separates are in the algorithm
rather than inputting a list and then
the really amazing smart thing that
happens in word de Becque is the-
sampling so the larger your data set is
the more vectors you're gonna have to
update through each run so instead of
going back and updating the word
embeddings for every single word you're
only going to update a small percentage
of them so you're gonna randomly select
some negative words to update and then
the positive word which was the word
that actually happened so that's kind of
how this is different and it's a lot
faster than the previous implementations
but so what do you do when you actually
get these word embeddings in the
original paper by me cloth what they had
is a list of analogical representations
that they understood very well and kind
of for me the easiest one to grasp was
capital cities and their countries so we
had this like understanding of like why
in DC in USA and things like that but
for food data I don't really know what
Apple - pear would be or like banana +
orange there's no like clear
relationship there so one of the things
we did to try to understand if our model
was doing what we expected was do some
dimensionality reduction and visualize
this data we were creating 17
dimensional vectors which obviously we
can't just visualize so there are a
bunch of different ways to do
dimensionality reduction like PCA linear
discriminant analysis T distributed
stochastic neighbor embeddings and what
we eventually landed on was using t-sne
to make these visualizations this is
what you're going to see most commonly
in papers about word Tyvek and one of
the reasons for that is it one kind of a
prestigious visualization challenge on
kaggle it's generally considered to be
better for visualization than pca
mostly because it solves this kind of
like crowding problem so you're going to
get kind of a better like visualization
at the end one of the things that's
really important to think about though
when you look at these visualizations is
that this is not a clustering algorithm
so when you're looking at it don't read
too much into cluster sizes or like how
far apart they might be and one of the
reasons for this is that the hyper
crammed attorney has a huge impact on
what visualization you're going to get
out of this so you could just like get
something different every single time
this is really just like sanity check
like isn't remodel like doing anything
at all that's useful to me so this is
hopefully some load kind of initially
what we got for our word embeddings for
kind of our more popular ingredients so
we can see like all of our boozes ended
up together coffee and espresso or close
together and then we have like a little
grouping of pastas up there so feeling
like pretty good about that but we're
gonna look at this from another
perspective as well so the other thing
we can understand is like we know as
humans how similar different were
different like ingredients or types of
food should be so
we can look at the cosine similarity of
these vectors just inside I really like
this person's website data aspirant they
explain all the different similarity
measures through Kung Fu Panda I don't
know why but I just think it's kind of
adorable that they do that so we're
looking at the cosine similarity between
these vectors we kind of understand some
of these things because we all are
people that eat food so looking at this
cosine similarity of cake to torte we
can see they're pretty similar but cake
is unfortunately very dissimilar to
salad
similarly chocolate and ganache are
quite similar along with cocoa Bokke
moly is very dissimilar to chocolate so
now that we have word embeddings that
we're feeling pretty good about what can
we actually do with them so it turns out
that word embeddings are pretty modular
when I first started working on this
that seemed kind of crazy to me that you
could just take these embeddings and
like add them up or subtract them and
concatenate them and they could retain
all their data the kind of classic
example with the modularity of word
embeddings is this example of king - man
plus woman equal equal and queen so the
idea that we had was that if we had all
these weren't embeddings we could add
them up we could just take all the
preparation steps and a recipe sum them
up and then that should represent our
recipe so that's kind of exactly what we
did once we did that again we went back
to t-sne
try to figure out if this was doing
something that we thought worked here is
kind of we've got our desserts down at
the bottom and green comfort food and
healthy food is kind of mixed together
because even our healthy food is not
that healthy and then kind of alcohol
being in purple and I know this is
really small but all the brownies are
kind of ended up together and all the
like drinks over here are together so
there's been different hyper parameters
in tuning this model but at the end of
the day my objective was for module and
our website to have kind of context
aware like like
relevant recipes it would make sense to
the user and wouldn't seem crazy so I
did make a lot of really hideous
spreadsheets with a bunch of different
implementations and hyper parameters for
this so we have I didn't really see much
of a difference between skip graham
implementation or continuous back of
words and it didn't seem to make too big
of a difference in terms of what
similarity metric that I used the
biggest thing that changed in this was
what we actually put into creating the
recipe Tyvek so to Train the word
embeddings our only option is to use the
preparation steps because we need full
sentences to have this like concept of
context words and target words but we
can also just like throw in the list of
ingredients or throw in the titles what
I found in the end was if you use the
ingredients you could find something
that had a very similar like flavor
profile but it would be a completely
different recipe so things like peanut
butter or like granola balls would come
out really similar to like a peanut
butter smoothie at the end of the day
like a smoothie is very different from
like an energy ball so we stuck with
just using preparation steps so the way
that we actually implemented this here's
like a little diagram of our
architecture we have a Python pack we
have Python script that is sending off
messages to our QR reader when either 12
hours have passed or a new recipe has
been created that's either going to
retrain a model completely or use an
existing model we pull down all of our
data about our recipes from our my
sequel database we kind of dump that
into Redis as our key value store and
then our API retrieves that and surfaces
it back to our app and to our website so
we're using Redis the Jensen
implementation for word avec python for
all of our different services and
scripts and then my sequel for our
recipes database so we are publishing
roughly 15 to 20 new recipes a week we
just kind of like fit the stale model to
it as soon as it's published and then
just retrain everything every 12 hours
and these are kind of sample results so
we've got this like cheese stuffed meat
thing you're just like a lot for me but
kind of cool we found all the other like
cheese stuffed meats so before we had
this project we could have like the best
we could have done is like show other
dinner recipes here and now we've gotten
into like a very specific type of recipe
that I'm pretty happy about here's again
some other example results for kind of
like a cheesecake cakey type thing
before we would have just shown kind of
random desserts here or like
high-performing desserts but now we can
show like really really really similar
recipes to here and it kind of works
across the board like it works for our
stir-fry that works for kind of booze
there are like some things that we have
to tweak in this so there can be recipes
that have like very similar preparations
but very different purposes so like here
are like meal prep smoothies are
prepared very similarly to a pina colada
but obviously the idea of like drinking
a pina colada versus like having like a
healthy smoothie in the morning is very
different so they're like little tweaks
that we do on top of this smoothies can
also be very similar to soups so we kind
of like fudge a little bit of that but
in general this feed is just straight
like word to the embeddings summed up
with cosine similarity and we've been
really happy with it so far we launched
this website about two months ago so at
the time we needed something that
wouldn't require any like feedback data
from our users so having this modular
really helped us a lot so in the future
we're hoping that we can use these
recipe of X for a lot of other things
like predicting performance of new
recipes based on the firm's of older
recipes kind of going back and creating
a more context to where recommendations
so combining collaborative attritional
clever filtering with our recipe
similarity metrics right now we have
some item to item and use it I tomorrow
filtering but we don't service it as a
module on its own because we want to
create some type of like cohesion in
terms of like big groups of recipes that
we're sharing you can also use this for
like making recommendations back to our
producers for what type of recipes they
should make in the future and it's just
like generally useful in machine
learning applications so that is the end
[Applause]
was that a factor here in terms of
choosing the show
similar to similar
similar in some other way what do you
mean so we chose recipes that were
similar in their process and their end
result because what we saw in our
session data for search history on our
website is that people would be looking
at similar recipes we saw like pretty
rarely that someone would like look for
a side and the main and a dessert
generally like people were like looking
for dessert at that time or they were
looking for like an entree and we saw
less like full meal planning we do see
that change during tentpole holiday
holiday events so around like
Thanksgiving and Christmas we do see
full meal planning but generally people
are kind of looking for like one thing
to eat like especially our audience like
most of the stuff is like kind of like
quick dinners so they are not looking
for like a full meal
ten minutes so so we have like five
thousand recipes so it retrains quickly
it's like I don't think we actually
really need to do it every 12 hours but
it's cheap and easy so we do it
yeah
so skip grin is predicting the context
words from the target words and
continues bag of words is predicting the
target word from the context words so in
continuous bag of words it's a little
bit faster that you're kind of in skip
grinning like artificially creating more
data points to train on so I'd actually
didn't see too big of a difference in
terms of the results of either of them I
think if I had a much larger data set
the efficiency would become more of a
concern but yeah that is basically a
difference you just swap around whether
predicting that context words are the
target words
yeah so we recreate the video and the
recipe ahead of time so we can actually
create the vector before we publish this
and then try to predict how well it's
going to do so right now we could try to
predict it based on performance on
Facebook or performance on our website
so that's generally how we do it
that's right there is like a default but
I played around with a couple different
versions of the context words window I
didn't see like tremendously huge
differences and then so I think you're
probably like pretty okay with the
default think for recipe of stiffs in
general like a smaller window probably
works better because they're not really
that long as instances I guess if you're
like looking at a philosophy paper maybe
like a longer window would make more
sense so we create all of our own
recipes yeah so we have people on staff
in New York LA and Japan that are making
these recipes actually in the UK as well
yeah that's nice there like a floor
below us
so they'll like send out a slack message
when they're done cooking and people
just like run downstairs and get the
leftovers
yeah there were either like either like
quick easy to make recipes or kind of
like really beautiful ones like we have
one that is like a cake that looks like
the inside of a geode or we have these
cookies where you like they're like they
look like an aquarium inside because
you're like melt the candy but then a
lot of the other recipes are like here's
like throw this chicken on a pan with
some vegetables and you're like you'll
have dinner in ten minutes there's like
very little cleanup involved in this
like I'd done NLP projects before we're
spending a lot of time cleaning and like
removing stop Birds but with the
subsampling in word Tyvek that wasn't
really necessary so it's actually like
pretty easy so all that stuff kind of
got left in and just like we like find
the embeddings for that and add
everything up
so the similar so looking for similar
recipes we're looking at bit repeated
searches so the actual text from the
search that they're looking for so then
you're like chicken pasta chicken bacon
pasta like that thing so we had like
kind of text similarity within that they
were looking at
oh yeah so it's so far I'm ignoring it
but it is like a thing that we need to
do we have like better metadata than
when we started
we initially had this we have like an
editor that people can go in and select
these tags and we didn't have a limit on
how many people could select so now we
just have a limit where it's like you
can pick one occasion or two occasions
or like one meal so once we put in these
kind of limitations we saw like a
dramatic increase in the quality of our
data so it hasn't been like a huge
interest to us right now but I think
it's like something that I want to get
back to you and I have time to time for
it yeah yeah I think that's what we're
moving towards now when we initially
created this module for our website in
our app we had like we're launching so
it was like we have 10 users which is us
so we don't really need their data but I
think the like end goal of this is yes
to like kind of make like a blended
model with like kind of a more
traditional recommendation engine and
this kind of recipe similarity
yeah we just tested this life-like
luckily we have some good back in
engineers and we were pretty set up to
like throw things on stage so like my
team kind of his acting is like a
separate kind of startup with in
BuzzFeed but luckily BuzzFeed has a
really good infrastructure for deploys
so we just did everything on Devin's
stage and then we're happy that it still
worked in prod cool all right thanks
guys
[Applause]